hello everybody and welcome to another
money-making method today I'm going to
be showing you how to make 700k or more
an hour uh with no starting cash
required the requirement for this method
is you will need to be able to get into
Warriors Guild so your attack and
strength levels have to add up to 130 or
you can have 99 in one of them more
likely you're going to have the 130
total and yeah this method can make you
over 700k an hour doesn't require any
starting cash and yeah let's get started
okay so to do this moneymaking method um
you don't need a lot of cash 50k 100K is
fine uh but what you will need is 65
strength and attack or 99 in one of them
this is to get into the warrior skill um
and to get there the easiest way is with
the games necklace just go to
borp and you're pretty much right there
you just have to go a little bit
West and on the map just this building
right here the Warriors Guild um so it
won't let you enter it unless you have
65 attack and strength that is the
requirement for this money-making method
and yeah get the money in your inventory
uh any weight reducing gear would be
useful uh but it's not really required
to be honest and yeah this is what
you're going to do so you're going to
come up here uh talk to this dude liyo
and you're going to buy out the plain
pizzas and the potato with cheeses and
then you're going to run over here to
the potion
shop and you're going to buy all of the
strength potion 3es
and then you're just going to hop worlds
um the way I do it I do both of these
because uh if you just buy from the one
shop you tend to get disconnected by the
server which is rather annoying so I
like to just run back and forth um
ideally you should be going for this
guy's Wares cuz they're just more
valuable um but you can see they're
bought out a lot more frequently but
depending on when you do this at what
time of night um the shops can be pretty
much fully stocked and yeah we'll do
this for an hour and we'll see how much
we actually managed to make okay so
we're about halfway through our hour um
it's going pretty decently not going to
lie it's pretty packed here but we still
are managing to get a good amount of
items uh it would be kind of more
recommended to do this during off peak
times obviously but you can see there
like I'm still getting the items there's
a couple other people doing it with me
for sure um
but it's honestly not too crowded of
course I'm not going to be lying that
when this video comes out it'll be much
more crowded but just keep in mind that
in a week couple days people will forget
about it and it's pretty reliable safe
Easy Money Maker once you can get into
the Warriors Guild um and yeah we'll
finish off this last half an hour and
we'll see how much money we managed to
make okay so we are done the 1 hour of
uh buying these items from the Warriors
Guild um it was roughly an hour probably
55 minutes to an hour or something and
yeah we will sell them back now one
thing you want to do first um just
because it makes the items easier easier
to sell is we're just going to decant
our potions cuz you may have noticed
they are three do potions um and we you
could sell them in three doses but it'll
take a lot longer so we'll just decant
them into four
doses and yeah we'll start by selling
off the stuff uh we're not going to wait
we're just going to sell it right away
just to show you that these items do
sell very
quickly and good sell that
too and get rid of the vials for the
maximum
profit and okay so let's just hit the
collect button and see much we made 1
hour of buying from the Warriors Guild
so we started with a 100K just recall so
we got a Bo 700k in 1 hour um pretty
nice considering this does not require
you to have any money to start with mind
you does require 65 attack and strength
but that's not a massive requirement or
anything and you don't need any money to
start with and it's pretty easy and safe
to get a starting cash stack start and
yeah I hope you guys enjoyed and I will
see you guys in the next video
n
[Music]